impliqué dans au nom vous habillez vous
valez sur petite culotte c'est pas bien
mais c'est comme ça dis moi je les
filles et de bouquets à la fin
en effet quand même que le real est prêt
c'est cool merci beaucoup monsieur je
vais tourner la peine à bonbons war
c'est gentil c'est gentil mais très bien
vous savez je suis pas trop loin de là
bas à vous êtes grand ces pratiques
attendez vous pouvez pas de monter
encore un petit de l'ue attendait jeu ça
vous embête pas si je mets ma pas du
tout vous êtes sorti attendait voilées
monter moi comme ça ouais c'est bien
trouvé à la chaire espagne
pardon vous tombez me regardez pas votre
petite culotte regardez-la pas c'est
gentil alors maintenant je sais pas
comment je vais défendre hadopi voilà
les antilles où il m
mais là
désolé
pas mal
[Musique]